mission accomplie donc pour david
saint-jacques je joins maintenant le
premier canadien avons vécu cette
expérience chris hadfield c'était en
2001 mais ça file bonsoir bonsoir
messieurs à fil vous êtes vous-même
sortie dans l'espace à deux reprises
alors techniquement on l'a vu c'est très
exigeant mais humainement quand la porte
s'ouvre
comment on se sent le premier moment de
quand vous êtes sortis de la sas et
entre dans l'espace dans l'univers seul
ça c'est un moment tellement
impressionnant et je le soutenais très
bien et donc j'ai vu ça spécifiquement
de le garder le réaction de david mais
il était comme comme moi tellement
occupés mais peut-être repris quelques
semaines j'aurai la chance de parler
avec david de de savoir exactement les
dépenses de ce moment ça c'est la
différence de la lave est la vie est un
événement expérience sans pareil parce
que c'est vrai que c'est tellement
exigeant sur le plan technique il y en a
pas beaucoup le temps je crois de
pouvoir regarder faut rester très
concentré sur ce qu'on fait oui sur
l'horaire
il n'y a aucune seconde qui dit de nazes
regarder l'univers regarde la terre
c'est toujours un chorégraphie vous êtes
comme un danseur dans ça et c'est
totalement planifiée il ya beaucoup
plein de choses à faire et vous êtes
vous vous concentrez de sa echakhch
petit choses techniques c'est nécessaire
de faire c'est le choses le plus
important mais en même temps d'être là
avec la terre la doite l'univers par
tous les noms et ella bleu profond d'âge
de sas et c'est difficile à comprendre
et à croire mais est ce nécessaire de
prendre quelques secondes de prince et
de sa est-ce que ça reste que ça
comporte encore des dangers vous êtes là
il ya des micro météorites qui frappe le
ska fans toujours c'est juste une
système qui garde le santé qui garde la
vie d'anas renard
et le système de temps en temps ne
fonctionne pas une panne et donc chaque
fois il ya un risque
tellement élevé le risque le plus grave
c'est lé lancement mais le deuxième
risque plus difficile plus élevé ça
c'est une sortie extravéhiculaire parce
qu'au fond ils ont ils sont juste
protégé par un scaphandre et d'un
vêtement enfant
oui c'est juste une scaphandre c'est
juste le tissu c'est pas une chose c'est
pas le même commune vaisseau spatial et
s'est gonflé de l'oxygène c'est toujours
un risque
il ya comme un renard je sais bien les
risques et les problèmes de ça et ça a
duré plus de six heures on dit que c'est
long est ce que c'est assez fréquent des
sorties de 7 longueurs la de cette durée
là oui c'est toujours plus difficile en
orbite que dans les simulateurs dans la
piscine à houston pour moi la première
sortie c'était juste pour moins que huit
heures et le deuxième set et 7h pour
david aujourd'hui je pense que c'était
6h30
ça c'est sexy comme c'est typique et
mais après ça ils étaient tellement
fatiguée c'est difficile à savoir le
niveau de fatigue l'eau mais après ma
première sortie avec hiller j'étais
absolument quoi énerver j'ai flotté est
resté pendant une demi-heure a pris
après la sortie si c'était tout ce que
je pouvais faire
et j'imagine pour david c'était la même
chose aujourd'hui
ce qui est fascinant c'est que après
toutes ces années après toutes ces
sorties on voit encore ces images et en
reste tellement accroché on reste
tellement fasciné par ça pourquoi vous
pensez que c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
le principe actif du monde de voir
morial dans les stades dans une sauteuse
x vécu l'ère c'est possible de voir à
les faire accepter au râteau et winnipeg
juste comme un coup d'oeil dans un
perspective et la vitesse c'est une âme
un tour dimanche à 90 minutes 2 et de
voir ce sens son vaisseau spatial s'est
juste vous dans l'univers seul comme
commune afin comme un petit point et
vous êtes petit mais en même temps vous
êtes là de savoir de goûter à de de
comprendre ça et ça c'est un prospecteur
difficile à croire dans la difficile à
croire dans le temps réel mais après
quelques quelques jours et quelques
semaines il reste sa vie david peut
interpréter ça et mieux savoir
exactement ce qui se passe ouais
formidable expérience mesures at-il
merci d'avoir partagé ces quelques
minutes avec nous merci c'est un plaisir
et félicitations à dévier de notre
agence spatiale
bien sûr merci merci